people are really good at copying each
other's faces
in fact we're the best but Don expansion
to facial expressions gorillas and
orangutangs even copy those expressions
it's been thought though that this
attention to faces and copying of facial
expressions was a feature of social
creatures now researchers have shown
that son bears can also copy each
other's facial expressions exactly
something only ever seen before in
primates scientists studied a group of
22 bears living together at the Bornean
son bear conservation center they
recorded hundreds of voluntary play
sessions between different pairs of
bears
and found the Bears made two distinct
open-mouthed facial expressions and one
the bear simply opens its mouth and the
other the bear opens its mouth while
wrinkling its nose and burying its top
teeth having two different facial
expressions allow the researchers to
judge whether the Bears were mimicking
their partners faces exactly if the
Bears only made one face it would be
impossible to tell whether the
expression was being passed from bear to
bear or if it was just a face that Bears
made while playing the videos revealed
that 13 of the 22 Bears copied their
playmates facial expression exactly
within a second of seeing it the
researchers were surprised to find exact
facial mimicry in son bears because the
bears don't have much of a social life
in the wild the Bears also showed what's
called social sensitivity or the ability
to sense the attention of others
eighty-five percent of the time that a
bear was making a face another bear had
a front-row seat finding such
sophisticated communication in the
antisocial son bear makes the authors
think facial mimicry might be more
common than previously thought it also
suggests that social skills like
communication can be useful adaptations
even for animals with seemingly simple
social lives now what the Bears are
actually communicating to one another
there's not much data on that yet but
one guess would be let's keep playing